pm says in fact via his minister this
morning that it's the natural order to
wait until the other two investigations
have finished and then he'll put himself
forward for investigation uh by the uh
committee here in the house of commerce
i think the motion that has been put
forward looks entirely reasonable and i
think it's an entirely reasonable time
uh to vote upon it um the motion is
saying that the investigation by the
privileges committee um shouldn't begin
until the police have fully reporters
and until the sugree report
has been published but it seems
perfectly reasonable to make the
decision that there should be such an
investigation
at this point and i think the difficulty
for conservative mps is if they are seen
to vote this down
okay there might be a promise that
there'll be another vote at a later
stage but clearly the intention of the
government is not to hold such an
investigation
and conservative mps who vote it down
today
can be accused of trying to cover up
this issue of trying to protect the
prime minister from an investigation
when clearly an investigation
is appropriate given that the prime
minister has already been found to have
broken his own lockdown laws
and what parliament needs to understand
properly is whether he has misled
parliament as well
you're a learned man uh there's been a
lot of comparison between a partygate
fine and a parking fine being comparable
um is it
no it's not
and we have to remember that this
you know
let's go back to the point at which
these offences uh may have occurred at
that point the government including the
prime minister was stressing that this
was of very great importance that we all
needed to play our part that this was
all about you know protecting lives and
that's why those rules were in place so
i think to dismiss these as as minor
issues given
the nature of the
lockdown rules
given that the public messages that were
coming from the government at the time
given that it was the prime minister
himself who decided to impose these
restrictions
uh i think the idea that he should just
be dismissed as as very minor offenses
are not really significant and also
there is this issue here of what the
prime minister has said to parliament
and the accusation of uh misleading
parliament now it doesn't matter you
know if the prime minister had stood up
and said you know i've never
committed a parking offense and he had
that would be a serious matter because
you you just can't mislead parliament
he says as you well know and i'll put it
to you again that on the two occasions
that he allegedly misled parliament
at that time that's what he believed and
we can't disprove that we don't know
what was in his head at the time
well i think that's
the argument about whether he has
mislead parliament or not and that is
what the privileged privileges committee
a committee made up of members of
parliament should investigate um i i
think there comes a point maybe maybe it
doesn't apply in the case of the
birthday party
but there comes a point where if it is
so obvious that it is a party where
there is so much evidence that there are
drinks there that there are nibbles
there maybe music is playing yeah we
don't entirely know we don't have all
the information yet um but if the
evidence is so
clear
that in fact you know it looked like a
party it sounded like a party
um then you know it is a party and it's
not credible for the prime minister to
claim
otherwise and the thought otherwise but
that's that's for the committee to
investigate and i think it is right that
it investigates that specifically
focused on the issue of whether he has
misled parliament or not but isn't the
point
one that you just touched on there that
we don't know yet what all the evidence
is so why are we um hang drawn and
quartering him when we don't actually
know what either the police or sue gray
have concluded
because the this uh this motion that the
labour party has put forward isn't
calling for him to be
hanged drawn or courted um what it's
saying is there should be an
investigation i think there is enough
evidence there
given the police's conclusion in terms
of the the the so-called birthday party
that there's a need for an investigation
um what conclusion should be reached
should be based on the evidence and as i
say we're not talking about this
investigation commencing until the
police process has been completed
but i think it is reasonable at this
point for parliament to make it clear
that the evidence is sufficient that uh
it is of such seriousness that they
should towards civilians but i agree the
investigation shouldn't start until the
police have completed their process
and the evidence can then be put before
the privileges committee